grazie stesso non so come poter partire
al meglio questo video 5 io devo
arrivato anche 10 allora devi premere
rete adesso grazie della serie devi
andare col mouse e cliccare link mese ci
sono ecco le questa è la vera dove si
entrato nella mappa sbagliata come così
esce ora che bello che i come aiuto
allora siamo in una mappa di parkour sé
ed è un accademia del parkour
si parte da dei livelli facili dovrebbe
diventare sempre un po più complesso e
si riesce a passare tutti i livelli di
20 esperto di parkour
ok quindi tipo l'università va bene
perché io aveva cavi almeno spero non ci
sia la matematica
va bene in ripetersi sono studiato
niente ragazzi qui in questa cosa deve
messo i piedi a un checkpoint quindi ai
piatti torni qua ed è la cosa più bella
che puoi vedere nella vita
1 ok no sono scarso nomi non mi guardare
non ricordare
ok ok dai è stata semplicissima ok io ho
trovato un po di difficoltà in questo
quindi si ha notizia
ebbene ragazzi sa bene allora qui va un
po peggio ok violo chi se ne frega no ci
ho provato almeno un tentativo ci devo
provare a casa
teoricamente si fa in quel modo solo che
siamo super mega lenti che mi bisogna
saltare all'ultimo
ok non è proprio banalissima invece ok
ma si è poi un consiglio al proprio io
faccio di solito la lasciamo qui ha
lasciato quando lei abituata lettera ma
perché scusami massone prendiamoci point
e lei si puote trasportati pò qua no
volevo almeno lei no vabbè questa cosa
incredibile prediletto quando smetti di
guardarla paese natale di quella sua
magia sai come funziona no non ho idea
però meglio che non debba toccare questi
cosi aiuto e affermate mi aspetto
niente stato il momento di euforia
incredibile allora credo che hai capito
se ti avvicini troppo poco cities
balzano via per vivere di cercare di non
andarci vediamo niente se non il
ghiaccio va bene non così perfetto così
attenzione però
mamma mia cosa ha fatto e fa sì non so
come devo la mia la troverà così la
lasciamo lì se la cultura di una volta
la guardo solo una volta per adesso
funziona non la guardiamo più ok allora
prova ha provato una volta senza mai
perché un'ora che ci provano riesco è
andata già vicinissimo eleonora che
prova senza cosa no l'ho preso malissimo
per vi prego
porca l'oca cioè di quasi è
difficilissimo io dico se come sta
piovendo nel cielo è un ombrello
anch'io sono anche secondo me ragazza
dovrebbe scapparmi il tastino aia il
tasto fan mi è scappato non volevo è
però anche a breve nei ragazzi è così e
così non lo fai controllare come un
botto a diventare tipo singolo che tipo
così vado mi sembra difficile ma questo
non era di ecco ecco ecco proprio così
poi ragazzi cioè non era un governo nera
non era proprio semplice come si fa
adesso purtroppo indovinati c'è un
casini crema come fai a dare a lato
è quello che si chiede di capire ma ho
già fatto eh sì
non so di che cosa c'è dopo è un buon
casinò perciò puoi fare ce l'ha fatta la
brava allora questo è l'inferno
benvenuta è un casino
siamo già al quinto anno dell'università
mista sentiamoli si tiene il conto e
dedicheremo anche qua per sempre per
sempre io ce l'ho fatta
meno male io ho aperto l'ombrellino una
mezza volta però una mezza volta sale no
nessuno ha visto niente ragazzi nessuno
ha visto per lasciare ok proviamo una
volta un test ok non proviamo più ho
capito esatto marcelo quasi allora ok
però è venuto lì fra semplicissimo devi
saltare è prenderlo o mi abbiano capito
il prossimo livello e poi devia no
quello dopo ancora più semplice questo
qua davanti che un casino ma devi
saltare dopo che lo premio prima e prima
si nota che si può fare in tutti i due
modi pre più semplice se salti prima ce
l'ho fatta ma cosa fa cit e salta prima
bravo e non ho visto niente non ho visto
niente non ho visto niente
ottavo un po troppo allora partita
no voglio sorprendervi tutti non si deve
saltare all'ultimo i maggio è un doppio
salto mannaia c'era il voto do c'era un
coso dopo le sei una cosa per saltare
ancora meglio però non è i molti
problemi guarda per terra mentre corri a
si è per così vedi quando devi saltare
loro funzionari usa chi ho visti questi
ragazzi è stato bello conoscervi state
pure lì però fate garanzia dai che ce la
fai
non mi sono neanche fermato è stato
incredibile allora qua già piango non
possiamo fare quello che sto vedendo
ragazzi impossibile come tagli come
potresti mai come è possibile chissà
cosa abbastanza incredibile qualcuno li
aiuti
dov'è possibile bravissimo come cadeau
caro poiché sono salvo che sto
aspettando hmi scada il ghiaccio lo
voglio fare
non posso starci cadute difficile che
farlo senza pensa che vi dovrà aspettare
per un po ci sono ok salta salta aiuto
offerto aperto cosa per sbaglio velai va
bene va bene va bene o nulla
non cambia nulla ok quindi ce l'avrei
fatta a priori hanno fatto tris
tarantino coop e rilassarsi un attimo
per canino cari le infinite imprecare
semi semi versi un non lo so un drink
qualcosa io lo prendo del tea pesca ce
l'hai
ma non sembra ci credo non ci credo
davvero fatto questo ti prego no no
voglio morire
basta no dai vi prego dei modi cos'è sta
roba è ucciso lui non pare livello dai
ragazzi appena voglio morire non
riuscirci subito no però non era una
moneta a cavallo come devono fare
aspetta io sono il set point
no veramente dai ragazzi basta quindi
scusami ma lanciarci point dopo è in
vista di no a quanto pare io pensavo di
averlo preso e il trucco e non cliccare
shift così si sia è in effetti numero
che per i suoi occhi cavo uscita io
basta non cliccare shift ragazzi eletti
si vabbè ma scorrendo il c troyes
scusatemi siamo ad un secondo avanti ma
mica go un po allora è questo e il 9 che
abbiamo fatto quindi manca al 10 ma dio
credo che siano 20 con sono 20 allora
qua devi fare esattamente con i percorsi
come devi saltare ritornare giusto
esatto che però è impossibile
no io riesco mi come fai a fare il salto
allora questo è mouse wide quindi è una
componente di guardare esattamente i
vivai ma cavolo ho capito perché tu sei
guardi dove vai incentivi il movimento
si si si io penso aveva già tipo non lo
sapevo
no l'ultimo è difficile allora 85
vediamo ma come fai a mettere il volto
bellissimo
voglio vederlo tutti aiutato lo faccio
per te 44 grazie sempre va negli album è
bravo a scuola
adesso per esempio fare nemmeno il primo
cioè prima riuscito sempre a fare il
primo perché in sé già pensando al
secondo è la mentalità del di farle con
calma con calma aspetta yoga fetta una
vai è difficilissimo destato che si può
funzionare che può funzionare perché hai
fatto che l'aiuta a peggiorare perché
almeno di solito di neymar è esatto dire
non si può fare quel sentimento si può
fare rimaniamo lì invece sfruttate
creata vedere se c'è un set al volo che
abbiamo raga assurdo cioè vi prego
aprono un grillino alla prossima credo
che non vi è invece invece si può fare
lance dai che dai raga dai vi prego
voglio tirare le testate al muro ci un
posto per adesso magari prego dai
io ve lo dico adesso lo staff la con ce
l'ho fatta
voglio andare voglio voglio morire
adesso voglio morire mi uccido vado al
check point e poi per farlo prendere
isolante e quindi manca solo fare quindi
per noi rimango qui a rivedermi per me
ne puoi star lì però bene quindi ragazzi
abbiamo fatto i primi dieci livelli
prima dei primi dieci classi di questa
accademia incredibile che mi farà
perdere tutti i capelli e ne ho tanti
quindi un problema speriamo che fare
riesca a farlo entro il prossimo
episodio
noi lottiamo con i prossimi dieci
livelli dell'academy del prossimo
appunto episodio di fort knight falcor
academy quello che lo chiamano così
qui niente se è piaciuto video lasciato
la cavino iscrivetevi ai tool players
van console che vi lascio lascio loro
canali descrizione è come sempre ci
vediamo al seguito
ciao ciao
[Musica]